so
if you start with your toes under
or
tap them on it like that all right so if
they're flat tap them
when the person comes
i've got a sense that
distance and i've got to not move too
quickly
and as he comes he thinks he's got me
here and i blend
as he
as his fingers are doing that
i must not
move to the side
well before he's got there whereas that
makes a great distance and i'm never
about to throw him
he has to feel like he's falling into
a vacuum a hole
so he's coming here
the next thing is
i mustn't come out like
so now i'm like really full up and you
know i'm i'm almost full higher we'll
say
what i need to do is i need to keep
quite small
so what when i come
even though my toes opened under so i
kept myself tight
so don't come up here because what
happens is he gets now heavy because
he's sort of he's seen me coming out and
even if he hasn't seen me come up come
up he sensed that there's something
growing
and it not
shrinking so i must feel
to him i must feel like he's got me